Realism is not exactly what we're going for her....
OHHHH!
Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier
and welcome to Turbo Dismount,
the game where I will destroy myself
for your entertainment.
Oh god!
Alright, hi guys, and welcome to Turbo Dismount.
I don't know why I didn't find out about this
game until just yesterday
but man! Is it exactly what I wanted in a game!
Anyway, so you're in a car-
there's so much to explain-
I love it already because I was able
to put my face and a giant moustache
on the car. That is absolutely astonishing to me.
AND all the game is
is you go and kill yourself!
THAT'S IT!
I love that!
I love it!
Oh, well, can't kill yourself very well
doing something slow as that, but
I put these turbo pads here and just-
BAAAM!
Oh my god!
What the hell BUS...?
Oh, here I am. Okay, I'm over here.
So, anyway
I haven't played it much, but I got a feel
for the system.
It's got a replay mechanic that you can display-
- and then reverse
Oh, it's so cool! I love it so much!
Anyway, I got a lot of stuff to show you, so
I got a lot of stuff to dick around with,
that's what I gotta do.
Alright, so this pose ain't working for me
You can actually change the pose up
and you can be sitting up here
and, my favorite, of course
is this one, because, for some reason
my character model-
which is the female character, by the way-
sticks its butt out
and starts shaking it around!
That's awesome!
Enough booty shaking,
we gotta go!
Let's go!
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Where did I go?
Oh, they didn't stop for anything,
did they?
Where did I go?
There- oh, there I am.
Oh, wow.
This is my favorite feature of it.
It's so cool, it's so cool.
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
"Stair Dismount"
I didn't make it though,
I need to make it farther
Nah nah nah nah nah.
I don't think that's gonna help;
you keep wanting to shake your butt
but I really don't think it helps.
O-kay!
Eh, why not, let's try it!
Alright, already scraping your feet on the ground
I like it, I like it, I like it
NOOO!
I gotta watch that again, please!
O-oh my god!
Queue the dramatic music.
Oh my god!
Oh, no no no no no-
Oh, my arm!
Nothing is ever gonna live up to that,
that's just too perfect,
there's no way that I could possibly beat it.
Oh!
Can that even- ?
Look at you, you're so adorable!
Oh, and there's a moustache on it!
Aw, you look so sad, though,
as if you're regretting- oh, you're
even shaking your head.
"This is a bad idea."
Too bad!
Yeah, buddy!
That's almost max power right there.
Come on!
Get it get it get it get it get it
Oh, no!
Oh my god.
"Hey, things are looking pretty good,
I feel good about this- oh, no-"
Realism is not exactly what we're going for-
I didn't even see it coming!
Ah, let's see that again in slow motion!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I love it!
Again! Show it to me again!
Look, I'm so relaxed!
I'm just like-
"I don't have a care in the world."
"Everything's gonna be just fine-"
I think what's really gonna help us
is coming at this at an angle.
And a different pose, of course.
Oh, Oh!
Paint me like one of your-
Oh my god.
Ooh! I think that was absolutely
max power right there.
Too bad I wasn't going straight.
Oh my god!
Oh wow.
Oh, so not-
I didn't even see that!
My torso is completely off of
my legs!
Now we just need an exercise in speed,
so let's see what happens.
My car disappeared!
"I dunno, what's gonna-"
Oh.
OH!
What did I- whoa!
I'm sorry.
I wonder what mystery vehicle I'm coming
down the runway on now?
Oh.
Oh, look at it go!
It's still going!
What the hell?
Oh, hi!
"I can't be bothered by anything."
"Oh, life is such a drag."
"I wonder where I'm going."
"Oh, who knows."
And it's still going!
Look at it go!
Alright, bring on the Corley!
Not a Harley or any-
That thing chased you down to death!
You slut!
Stop spreading your legs like that.
Even though your leg is clearly
all the way over there.
"Nothing could go wrong today-
uh oh.
Well, that doesn't- oh my god!"
Alright, so that was Turbo Dismount.
That is amazingly fun!
I am putting this on my list of games
to play with Bob when he comes to visit me
or when I go to visit him,
because us playing this game together
would be so much fun!
Anyway,
if you wanna see more of it,
let me know in the comments below.
Thank you all so much for watching.
And, as always,
I will see YOU
in the next video.
Bye-bye!